wahrscheinlich hat das Kind wirklich
jeder an ferngesteuertes Auto bis auf
mich jetzt könnte ich mir einfach selbst
eins bauen im 3D Drucker machen
Steuerung die Stars aber wieso sollte
man sich den Müll machen komplett neues
Auto zu machen wenn ich doch einfach
schon ein Auto hier habe dass ich
einfach umbauen kann zu einem
ferngesteuerten echten Auto und das
Testen als auch gleich auf der
Rennstrecke aber erstmal muss es
natürlich gebaut werden was ich auch die
Profis vom Volkswagen economy Service
nicht entgehen lassen wollen die auf
dieses Video auch reagieren werden und
von denen dieses Video auch unterstützt
wird so also irgendwie muss das Ding
ferngesteuert werden so das heißt das
Teil
Lenkradsperre perfekt oha wo ist näher
gekommen das Teil muss ich einmal von
dem Motor drehen lassen und ich merke
gerade dass es gar nicht mal das ist
echt von meinem Stand richtig schwer so
muss ein krasser Motor sein
kleineren Motor das muss jetzt nicht so
fest sein trotz natürlich halbwegs genau
gesteuert werden und die Bremse die
müssen jetzt nicht so genau steuern aber
da muss halt ordentlich Power drauf
kommen will ja auch das Auto wirklich
steht als erstes brauchen wir eine
programmierbare Fernbedienung und die
hat einfach mal zwei Wochen Lieferzeit
gehabt mit dem Teil werden normal
Modellflugzeuge ferngesteuert wird so
tief nur die gar nicht so tief
ich meine was für ein kleines
Modellflugzeug funktioniert bestimmt
auch für ein anderthalb Tonnen schweres
Auto das ist jetzt dasselbe Motor der
mal das Gaspedal bedienen soll und das
ist so ein kleiner Sender oder ein
Empfänger besser gesagt das hier ist der
Sender unsere Film Bedienung
[Musik]
ich finde das total geil weil
das ist schon mal gut ja aber ich will
ja eigentlich dass ich hier das Lenkrad
dann habe und das Gas soll er so sein
wenn man nach vorne Gas gibt vom Ende
ist das jetzt mal hier bin hier im
Channel 1 drin und will aber auf dem
Channel 2 gehen so und jetzt sollst
theoretisch passieren wenn ich nach
vorne und nach hinten gehen ja
so das heißt ich mache Gas
und dann drückt ihr einfach hier so aufs
Gas das ist ultra lustig pass auf
[Musik]
und jetzt
das ist so lustig
es gibt nichts krasseres ich kann jetzt
einfach hier zu machen und gib einfach
Gas
und dann geht einfach auf das Gaspedal
und der hat auch echt
gut Power also das
Gaspedal ist überhaupt kein Problem ich
wollte kein Test ob dein Feuer löschen
schieben kann aber ich glaube nicht er
ist auf jeden Fall schwer
und es ist halt überhaupt kein Problem
das ist so krass der ist übel strong
also Beschleunigung haben wir schon mal
gemacht jetzt Bremsen dafür gibt's den
anderen Motor der ein bisschen mehr
Power und zufälliger
Scheibenwischermotor also ja wer von
euch schon mal im Auto getüftelt hat da
dürfte sowas irgendwie kennen den steckt
jetzt immer das gleiche Stromnetz wie
auch den anderen Motor plus zu plus
minus zu minus das ist mega der
Kabelsalat hätte ich auch schöner machen
können aber es funktioniert hier ist der
Empfänger und wir wollen für die Bremse
Channel 3
wow
okay das da ist gefährlich obwohl er
jetzt eigentlich sich nicht bewegen
sollte tut das
wenn man das Teil ein bisschen benutzt
dann entwickelt sich irgendwann
eigentlich noch einen anderen Motor also
noch mal quasi genau den gleichen wie
hier nur kleiner so kommt er jetzt
leider weg tschüss Scheibenwischermotor
also ich kann jetzt mit der
Fernbedienung hier Gas geben aber ob der
jetzt genug Power hat das wirklich zu
betreiben findet man raus also wenn man
jetzt irgendwie hier richtig richtig
fest einspannt dann kann man damit auf
jeden Fall Vollgas geben man kann auch
genau fein einstellen wie viel Gase
geben soll warte mal ich kann auch
einfach mal direkt den Motor anmachen
weil im Leerlauf kann ich ja richtig Gas
geben
geil
aber werde ich nicht würde jetzt einfach
losfahren und ich kann halt hier super
fein steuern wie schnell ich fahren will
mal ein bisschen
oder halt Vollgas
es ist
aber aufpassen weil das kann dann schon
mal nach hinten losgehen kommen wir zur
Bremse
souverän das ist glaube ich die
wichtigste Funktion und da wird diese
gigantische Schrittmotoren in der Lage
ist das Lenkrad zu drehen um das zu
testen brauchen wir erstmal eine
Vorrichtung also man könntest du jetzt
irgendwie hier in die Tür reinmachen ich
habe allerdings keine Ahnung was deine
Elektronik ist also hier ist auf jeden
Fall der
Türöffner und man will natürlich auch
jetzt Auto nicht komplett schrotten
damit wir müssen ja noch damit zur
Rennstrecke fahren und damit brauchen
wir die Straßen Zulassung jetzt wäre
eine Option theoretisch irgendwie das
hier auszumontieren und dann an zwei
Punkten den Motor dran zu machen und
dann hier per Gurt das übers Lenkrad das
wird gehen oder alternative man schaut
hier einfach rein weil hier ist schon so
ein Loch drin oder man könnte auch
einfach generell da die da raus machen
und dann da rein darüber reingehen und
hat dann quasi von unten den Motor dran
der hat quasi hier so ein Seil zieht der
wiederum dann das Lenkrad sieht ja ich
glaube das ist das smarteste das heißt
wir machen jetzt hier meine Holzplatte
drauf spannen wir haben mit zwei
Spanngurten hier fest da kommt dann der
Motor drauf und auf dem Motor so ein
Gurt der dann quasi das Lenkrad dreht
und das Brett fürs Lenkrad das Schneiden
als auch direkt das ist eventuell etwas
schwer
[Musik]
so das riecht jetzt erstmal schön nach
Holz
ich glaube ich habe sowas fettes noch
nie mit der Katze geschnitten
[Musik]
und irgendwie muss der Motor der hängen
kommen der irgendwie auch auf das
Lenkrad zugreifen können das heißt wir
müssen da irgendwie noch ein Zahnrad
dran machen das kann man sich auch dran
kleben deswegen haben wir jetzt einfach
so diese absolut professionelle Platte
die hinten einfach so Holzteile hat und
die kann man jetzt hier einfach komplett
professionell Eindrücken Spieler noch
Kabelbinder drumrum machen und dann geht
das dann verlängere ich das einfach mal
und hier wird es dann später abgesägt
[Musik]
nachdem die Grundplatte samt Abschrägung
fertig ist muss noch der Motor befestigt
werden und wie so oft fällt hier die
Wahl auf den 3D Drucker der die
Halterung genauso entstehen lässt wie
sie davor am PC konstruiert wurde
[Musik]
mir ist gerade ein kleines aber feines
Problemchen aufgefallen und zwar immer
wenn ich irgendwas ans Lenkrad dran
pressen will dann passiert
ja und zwar dauerhaft ich hoffe dass man
da irgendwas ein Elektronik abstöpsen
kann das hier ist der Sicherungskasten
volkswagen golf v
sicherungskastendiagramm
so und mit der Sicherung entfernt
kann das Auto jetzt nicht mehr
hochnehmen
ey das ist so schwer ich installiere das
jetzt mal
dann spare ich mal den guten Gurt das
ist auch immer professionell gemacht
kann man nichts sagen so dann ist
Lenkrad
dann ganz professionell mit Kabelbindern
wird das hier gemacht und jetzt zum
Keilriemen so dann justiere ich das noch
mal
genauer Spannung ist
auf jeden Fall muss ich noch ein
bisschen hier am Lenkrad was einstellen
muss ein bisschen weiter rein
[Musik]
ja jetzt ist es perfekt ja und jetzt
dreht sich tatsächlich frei
[Musik]
ist das geil okay aber kann ich damit
jetzt auch lenken um das herauszufinden
brauchen wir Elektronik eine Menge
Elektronik sogar zusammen mit der
Technik für die anderen beiden Motoren
ist mittlerweile übrigens alles schön
ordentlich verkabelt damit später nicht
bei voller Fahrt ein Kabel locker wird
und das Auto dann so lange in eine
zufällige Richtung Vollgas gibt bis es
von einer Wand gestoppt wird für die
Anbringung der beiden anderen Motoren im
Fußraum gibt's mittlerweile auch eine
schlaue Lösung aber bevor ich die jetzt
teste schaut euch erstmal an welche
nicht kann zu schlauer Herangehensweise
ich zuerst versucht habe also irgendwie
müssen wir jetzt diese Motoren da rein
hier ist Kunststoff also theoretisch
kann ich hier einfach Schrauben
durchbohren und einfach komplett in den
Boden reingehen ich glaube aber nicht
dass es so gut wäre fürs Auto also man
könnte den Motor auch hier nach oben
machen oder von oben kommen dass wir
natürlich auch gehen wisst ihr was
machen also ich muss zugeben aus dem
Winkel kenne ich ein Auto überhaupt noch
gar nicht
so einfach Schrauben geil
[Musik]
also eben musst du noch eine sein weil
oder auch nicht also das sind jetzt
Kabel drunter ich weiß es nicht ob das
zu gut ist aber ich sehe da jetzt nicht
wirklich eine Möglichkeit ist einfach in
die Schrauben rein zu schrauben ich kann
höchstens noch den Rest der Verkleidung
hier einfach abmachen was ist eigentlich
dahinter wir schauen mal nach
wie weit ist mal wie so oft keine Lösung
oh vielleicht doch ja geil ich weiß
nicht was das fachmännisch korrekt war
aber es sieht jetzt noch Sachen aber ich
kann dir ja auch nicht einfach eine
Schraube reinschrauben viel schlauer ist
es einfach alles auf dem Brett zu
schrauben und dann das Brett einfach in
den Fußraum zu stecken ja und ich lenke
jetzt einfach mal ne also halt mit einer
Fernbedienung
okay das ist insane geil ey das ist
einfach insane geil oh mein Gott die
Rede bewegen sich auch immer die ganze
Zeit
ist ja geil ey das ist viel zu heftig
aber ferngesteuertes bewegen zu können
ihr seht das Lenkrad obwohl halt keiner
dran ist und man kann das halt richtig
fein justieren einfach oder halt auch
richtig schnell lenken
du geil also das heftigste ist halt
einfach wie genau meiner steuern kann
also ich kann halt echt einfach komplett
entspannte Kurven machen und so richtig
fein justieren dass ich das Rad nur so
minimal dreht oder halt einfach voll
reinhauen
einfach fett eine bewegt hat im Zweifel
jetzt das Auto das ungefähr 1,5 Tonnen
wiegt beim volkswagen golf Varianten
wird wenn man die Bremsscheiben hier
betätigen kann okay ich setze mal die
Platte hier rein so und es ist das jetzt
nicht unbedingt die feine englische Art
aber Alter der Vogel hat mich fast
umgebracht aber ich mag auch ein Stein
drauf boah da bekommt das Wort Bleifuss
echt eine ganz andere Bedeutung
ha okay ich kann Gas geben ich finde es
so geil ich fühle mich wie ein Kind das
einfach ein ferngesteuertes Auto
geschenkt kriegt zum ersten Mal in
seinem Leben was irgendwie auch der Fall
ist okay und jetzt die Bremse erstmal
sanft und dann fester
das funktioniert halt einfach auch
jetzt wo alle einzelnen Funktionen
funktionieren geht's ab ins wunderschöne
Österreich wo wir das ganze
Zusammenspiel testen warum in Österreich
fragt ihr euch weil sich da der
Salzburgring auf dem man auch als
Privatpersonen Rennen fahren kann und
seine geniale Crew befindet die uns
gegen alle Erwartungen einfach auf ihre
absolut geilen Rennstrecke fahren lässt
mit einem unbemannten Auto das zu 80% in
eine ihrer Leitplanken Brettern wird und
das mitten in den Alpen
also ich gebe jetzt quasi noch kein Gas
die Bremse geht automatisch an wenn ich
hier loslasse und jetzt zweite
Handbremse mal locker
wenn ich ihn jetzt auf die Stelle dann
fährt er gleich los ne also
jetzt ist auf drive
also die Bremse ist nicht fest genug als
das der das bremst und so können wir
natürlich auf keinen Fall fahren
deswegen unternehmen wir noch mal ein
paar Änderungen am Bremsmechanismus so
dass ich beim nächsten Test hoffentlich
keinen heldenhaften Hechtsprung zur
Handbremse machen muss anstatt dass der
Motor jetzt permanent die Bremse
gedrückt hält wenn ich die Fernbedienung
loslasse bremst das Auto nach der
Erinnerung nun nur wenn ich wirklich
aktiv den Bremsen Joystick drücke damit
fehlt zwar der sogenannte Failsafe bei
dem das Auto automatisch zum Stillstand
kommt selbst wenn ich die Fernbedienung
fallen lasse aber dafür funktioniert die
Bremse jetzt so lange wie ich will warum
die Bremse davor nach 5 Sekunden schlapp
gemacht hat wissen wir aber immer noch
nicht Problem ist jetzt glaube ich
gefixt aber bevor ich jetzt eben halt
auf Drive Stelle was vorhin jetzt nicht
so gut funktioniert hat würde ich ihn
jetzt erstmal auf N stellen ne Leerlauf
einfach und dann würde ich mal probieren
ob ich den wenn der auf Bremse ist
schieben kann oder nicht dann sehe ich
halt ob die Bremse halt halbwegs passt
bevor ich es wirklich drauf ankommen
lasse
okay also ich kann jetzt mal versuchen
den zu schieben
okay passt schon passt schon fast schon
ja also das bremste also jetzt schon
langsam aber jetzt nicht richtig schnell
ja wir haben eine lange Gerade
okay dann würde ich den jetzt einfach
mal gerade lenken kannst du noch mal
anziehen weil das kann ja schon mal
machen
und das funktioniert auch extrem geil
für den mal genau gerade ausrichten und
ich setze mich jetzt einfach mal ins
Auto rein damit ich noch im Zweifel die
Handbremse ziehen kann Alter
also ich drück die Bremse und
idealerweise fährt jetzt nicht los er
steht
wir sind ja geil ja brems gut genug
tschüss
[Musik]
ist ja geil
der Prinz
also ich glaube jetzt nur noch gebremst
ja ich habe irgendwie Gas gegeben und du
bremst Geizhals und dann ja das hat er
gepasst also man sieht jetzt im Zweifel
Handbremse fertig außer man sitzt halt
nicht drin
hey das ist viel zu krass
das ist zu dumm
also muss echt erstmal ein Gefühl
kriegen einfach aber das kriegt man auch
echt gut raus
das ist so heftig ey das ist echt die
komplette Härte also ich gebe noch nicht
Gas
und Steuer das Teil einfach fern und
Bremse geht einfach immer noch und ich
würde sagen ich gebe jetzt ein bisschen
Gas
voll weggezogen er wird auf jeden Fall
lang brennt weg aber er brennst es ist
schon echt mal nice aber ich glaube
jetzt noch mal Zeit auszusteigen also
ich bleibe jetzt mal hier rechts neben
dem Auto macht Bremse
dann Drive von außen ist nochmal viel
geiler Alter Holi oh mein Gott wie sich
das fühlt sich viel zu krass an das ist
das komischste Gefühl überhaupt ich kann
es euch einfach nicht erklären und ich
kann natürlich lenken
[Musik]
und das Auto fährt jetzt einfach ohne
Fahrer
wie geil ist denn das und erstmal
Vollbremsung
die können jetzt spektakulärer sein aber
hey es ist so ein bisschen das Gefühl
als würde man mit seinem Auto spazieren
gehen ja ich teste noch mal bremsen okay
ich teste
man muss es auch ein bisschen intuitiv
im Gefühl haben wie das so ist mit dem
Bremsen und Gas geben dass ich dann auch
im Notfall wirklich Bremse und nicht
irgendwas dummes macht und dann würde
ich jetzt sagen er fährt jetzt los und
ich gebe jetzt mal Gas
und jetzt bremst der hoffentlich oder ja
also ich bin halt voll auf der Bremse ne
ja
war ich gar nicht ich war nicht voll auf
der Bremse es ist so dumm das ist das
gefährlicher ich habe halt nach unten
gezogen und nicht nach links das heißt
ich war halt fast gar nicht auf der
Bremse und ich dachte ich bin auf der
Bremse aber gleich haben wir eine Kurve
das wird auch noch spannend das geht
noch ein bisschen Gas
das sieht schon gut ab und jetzt nochmal
Vollbremsung ja und jetzt bremst du halt
auch ne passt schau mal ob ich mich
jetzt an so ein leichtes schnelleres
Level gewöhnen kann Hilfe
okay also ist jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
so gut dass ich hier drin bin ich
versuche noch mal rauszulenken Lenkung
ist auf Anschlag
und das macht der Mühe los das ist
überhaupt kein Problem also wir machen
jetzt mal hier vorne die Kurve und die
mache ich erstmal ein bisschen langsamer
es ist so verrückt wie sie das Lenkrad
dreht und du schaust ins Auto an und es
ist aber trotzdem so dass er keiner
dahinter sitzt ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen auf die Beschleunigung gegeben
boah
[Musik]
es ist echt schwierig hier zu sehen was
abgeht kurz mal nicht im Pascal
reinfahren
okay hat geklappt ey das ist voll geil
es funktioniert viel besser als
befürchtet man muss sich noch eine
Steuerung gewöhnen und dann glaube ich
kommen ja auch mal ein bisschen
schneller durch die Gegend düsen
ganz anderes Gefühl wenn man so richtig
die Lichter einfach auf sich zu fahren
sieht ich finde das einfach mega geil
also ich will jetzt auch nicht
beschleunigen oder so aber das ist jetzt
einfach so fährt
ohne dass dein Fahrrad drin ist ist
schon mega geil bisschen mehr geht noch
bisschen mehr geht noch
so geil also ich würde sagen die Runde
geht erst mal uns jetzt noch die Frage
wie viel Blödsinn wir noch damit machen
können also die nächste Stufe wäre jetzt
einmal ein bisschen schneller zu fahren
ne so wir drehen jetzt um und dann
können wir richtig dort Person mäßig
fahren ich wollte gerade schon spielen
sagen aber es ist halt einfach kein
Spiel sondern solche Leben indem man auf
der Ladefläche von den Jungs drauf sind
ist ja geil alter das ist so wild kannst
auch ein bisschen mehr Gas geben ich bin
nur vorsichtig oh mein Gott die sind so
schnell unterwegs also die Jungs die uns
gerade hier fahren die haben richtig
Bock auf die Nummer die denken sich so
gibt doch Gas
ich habe mal Vollgas gegeben
das war bestimmt eine gute Idee also ich
fahre hier so besoffener also wenn du
damit durch die Gegend fährst dann hält
dann hätte ich auch immer die Polizei
komplett auf hey noch mal Gas geben hier
zack boah ist das krass ey das ist so
das ist so eine
ja es wird besser weil Uhr das ist so
ein heftiger Erfahrung die einfach sonst
keiner wahrscheinlich niemals in seinem
Leben machen wird aber ich war halt wie
so ein komplett betrunken das ist viel
zu krass einfach
und jetzt die Kurve auch oh Hilfe
wir fahren 40 das ist so absurd wir
heizen jetzt durch die Kurve hier da
kann man auch mal Gas geben
[Musik]
ja gar keinen Stress alter das ist so in
zehn das da ist gerade ein Auto und
anderthalb Tonnen schweres Auto und ich
längst gerade in der Videospiel also ich
water also ich glaube das ist echt das
heftigste was gemacht haben ich glaube
wir fahren auch gerade 40 km/h wow
war Absicht scheiße das war nicht
Absicht
ey ich gebe gerade zu das fühlt sich
überhaupt nicht realistisch an das fühlt
sich nicht an als wäre das gerade das
echte Leben weil es auch viel zu absurd
ist Alter man kann halt richtig gut
lenken hier die Lenkung ist auf jeden
Fall strong die geht komplett direkt
aber zu direkt sogar also man gibt also
auch eigentlich ist alles ein bisschen
zu empfindlich deswegen ist auch so
schwierig Alter ich sehe uns hier so ein
Unfall machen
alter das ist viel zu krass wo ETF das
ist das heftigste überhaupt und ich
glaube hinter der Kamera wollte auch mal
gleich testen oder
noch nie
Alter
ich zitter am ganzen Körper das ist das
40 war das schnellste Alter ihr seid
echt die krassesten das ist echt das
absolut geilste das ist so unfassbar
heftig es fühlt sich auch überhaupt
nicht mehr realistisch an es ist
komplett heftig ich kann noch mal
Vollgas geben und dann halt aber Bremsen
auch direkt wieder also gib mal Gas ich
mache jetzt auch Vollgas komm Jungs
wollen das unbedingt sehen
[Musik]
schnell geworden
aber ich werde nicht also ich kann ja
nicht die ganze Folge geben das Problem
ist dass die Lenkung halt sehr sehr fein
ist und darum gehe ich da einfach lieber
auf Nummer sicher
[Musik]
Alter ist das Wild kannst auch mal mehr
Gas geben da vorne ist die Kurve richtig
heftig aber da muss ich jetzt echt
aufpassen weil holy Shit weil da fahre
ich gerade wirklich um Psychopat
[Musik]
h ja ich glaube das voll im Griff
geil 50 km/h wurden sie gerade gesagt
und ab in den Boxenstop absolut geil das
war mit Sicherheit das beste Video
überhaupt die Kfz-Mechatroniker vom
Volkswagen economy Service die werden
auf jeden Fall begeistert sein kann ich
mir nicht anders vorstellen also
vielleicht gibt es auch die eine oder
andere Sache an meiner Herangehensweise
die man kritisieren könnte die werden
auf jeden Fall auf das Video reagieren
also haltet die Augen offen und ich bin
damit raus